we pray with me spirit of the Living God
come now and grow our faith deepen our
hope and strengthen our love and inspire
within each of us the desire to be your
faithful friends forever amen so curious
things can happen during a drought
things that nobody thought possible
unbelievable things given all of the
weather that we've had recently the idea
of a drought seems somewhat far removed
and it's hard to remember that just over
the summer over fifty percent of the
country was in drought the drought
covered a comparable geographic area to
the same drought of the to the drought
of the 30s even though it hasn't been in
place as long and even though the
memories of the 1930s Dust Bowl are
distant they still haunt us Steinbeck
describes this opening scene and The
Grapes of Wrath in the last part of May
the sky grew pale and the clouds that
had hung in high puffs for so long in
the spring were dissipated the Sun
glared down on the growing corn day
after day until a line of brown spread
along the edge of each bayonet the
clouds appeared and went away and in
awhile they did not try anymore the
weeds grew darker green to protect
themselves and they did not spread
anymore the surface of the earth crusted
a thin hard crust and as the sky became
pale so the earth became pale pink in
the red country and white in the grey
country in the water gullies the earth
dusted down in dry little streams
Gophers and ant lions started small
avalanches then it was June and the Sun
shone more fiercely the brown lines on
the corn leaves widened and moved in on
the central ribs the weeds frayed and
edged back toward their roots
the air was thin and the sky more pale
and every day the earth paled you can
sense the life just draining out of the
place can't you you can feel the sense
of foreboding because just as the land
begins to crack into crumble so does the
community that lives on it it's in the
midst of this pale and fraying landscape
that Steinbeck finds and follows the
Joad family trying to see this new
reality this new life through their eyes
and in a radio interview just shortly
after the novel was published sign back
commented on how this French author had
once said that only Kings gods and
heroes were the fitting subjects for
literature because a writer can only
write about what he admires Steinbeck
said since our race admires gallantry
the writer will deal with it where he
finds it he finds it in the struggling
poor now Steinbeck wants us to see the
world differently he invites us to find
treasure and admiration where we didn't
even think to look and the Old Testament
texts today asks the same thing of us
you don't hear it in this translation I
didn't notice that until it was read out
loud but in the text that I was looking
at the word of the Lord comes to Elijah
in the wilderness and says get up go to
Zarephath look I've appointed a widow
there to provide for you and so Elijah
gets up and he goes to Zarephath and
look there's the woman as soon as he
enters the gate it's almost as if she
was waiting for him to arrive but then
when he asks her for bread she says look
I don't have anything to give you I'm
out here gathering two sticks so that i
can go home and make a tiny fire and
cook a handful of meal for my son and I
because that's all we have left and
we're going to eat it and then we're
going to die maybe Elijah hasn't noticed
that there's a drought in
the land but it turns out that Hope has
a lot to do with how you see she knows
herself to be a poor woman who's no
longer able to care for herself or her
son she's a desperate victim of cruel
chance and there is nothing left to her
life except its bitter end but Elijah
sees her differently because God told
him what to look for Elijah season this
woman not only someone who cares for
herself and her child but someone who's
going to care for him too he sees her as
capable and courageous kind and generous
she's a woman who will persevere and
provide for all of them despite the grim
circumstances but then again Elijah
knows how all of this works by now the
word of the Lord comes instructs he
obeys the word of God is sure the first
time that this happened the word of God
came to Elijah just after he had
declared that there would be a drought
throughout the land and told him go east
hide yourself by a certain stream there
for I have commanded the Ravens to
provide food for you can you imagine
what Elijah was thinking in that moment
oh great God perfect plan but apparently
he couldn't come up with a better one
because he did go and it all unfolded
just says God said it's as if God was
speaking reality into being so this time
around Elijah has a little more
confidence I'm sure in the Word of God
go I've appointed a woman look there's
the woman and so he gets there and he
knows that she's been appointed by God
he knows it he trusts it and he pushes
it to the point of absurdity he asks her
go and get me a little bit of water and
then he says and bring me a little bit
of bread and when she says I have a
handful of flour that I'm about to cook
for my son and I we're going to eat it
and we're going to die he says sure sure
sure do exactly what you just said only
make a little bit for me first
and then make something for you and your
son it will all be fine don't be afraid
she has been appointed by God and Elijah
knows it but nobody told her the Word of
God is not coming clearly ringing in her
ears with step-by-step instructions and
words of assurance she's just out one
morning collecting firewood and she
comes across this poor beggar now
remember that Elijah has been out in the
woods for months as the Ravens provide
him food day by day in the morning in
the evening and so there's no halo of
light around his head there's no parting
of the heavens as the Word of God or the
finger of God points down and announces
him as the prophet of the Lord there's
just this guy who's been living in the
woods for months and looks and smells
like he's been living in the woods for
months also on top of that he's clearly
a foreigner he doesn't look like her he
doesn't talk like her in fact she knows
right away that he's an Israelite how he
came to be in her town she has no idea
so when he asks her water she complies
without a word but when he pushes
further she scoffs at him and his
response is kind of crazy you know he
says sure sure do what you just said
only make me a little bit first first he
comforts her do not be afraid then he
demands that she provide for him before
she provides for herself or her own son
and then he prophesized for thus says
the Lord the meal shall not lack the oil
shall not be spent until the day that
the Lord brings rain onto the earth this
is not her God she knows nothing of the
God of Israel the story rushes forward
we know that she goes and does exactly
what Elijah says but is worth pausing
for a moment to consider that she had a
few other options at this point she's
sir sizing her own agency God's will is
not her destiny she's making difficult
choices in this moment she doesn't say I
don't know you she could have gone home
and she could have closed the door she
could have come up with any number of
excuses for why it was wiser more
reasonable safer for her to just ignore
him she could have cursed him for not
preparing a little bit better to provide
for himself the way she has been
struggling to do for herself in her own
family through this time of trial she
doesn't do any of those things the other
thing she doesn't do one of the other
things that she doesn't do I'm sure
there are many she doesn't say my family
comes first and i think this one is
actually much harder than the first
because her decisions affect not only
her own life but the well-being of her
son and so she could have said i have a
responsibility to my son above all else
and who here would falter i think this
may be one of the most dangerous forms
of idolatry that we have to deal with
today people justify unethical actions
for the good of their own children for
the security of their own family and at
what cost she doesn't do that either
instead she hears Elijah's Proclamation
the god of Israel's provision and
promised and inexplicably she believes
it or at least she's willing to take a
chance on it she goes on and she does
exactly as Elijah says and the flower is
not spent and the oil does not lack for
many months until the day that the Lord
brings rain on the earth it's through
her charity that God's miracles are made
possible now I pray that God will spare
us all from such a time of trial but I
also pray that through everyday acts of
Valor God might prepare us and
shape us into the sort of people who
could have the grit to act like this
woman does if we can learn little by
little to pay attention and make
ourselves available to the people around
us I mean start start with the people
who clean your office or your dorm room
or the folks that you see on your
shuttle commute every single day start
with the people that are right around
you the people that you work with the
people that you live with if we can
learn to make ourselves available to
these people if we can learn to look and
wonder whether each person might be a
prophet in passing or perhaps someone
appointed by God to interrupt our lives
if we can listen for a word from God out
of the mouths of strangers or surprising
people that we wouldn't have expected if
we can convince ourselves that God's
Word is often uncomfortable and costly
and yet makes us alive and creates new
realities before us if we can learn to
share and also what is sometimes more
difficult to receive from each other
just in small ways then maybe hopefully
we would not be so ill-equipped during
times of drought maybe we too would be
people who could act with gallantry and
through us God's grace might be revealed
in the world God let it be so